let me ask a silly question but we'll
say it with a straight face impossible
so let me mention Elon Musk what are
your thoughts about he's more you're
more on the physics theory side of
things he's more in the physics
engineering side of things and in terms
of SpaceX efforts what do you think of
his efforts to uh get off this planet
well I think he's the other guy who's
sent me serious about getting off this
planet I think they're two of us were
semi-serious about getting off the
planet what do you think about his
methodology and yours
when you look at them don't and I don't
be against you because like I was so
excited that like your top video is
reycarts file and then I did your
podcast and we had some chemistry so
it's oom DUP yeah and I thought okay I'm
gonna betray her sauce so just as I'm
coming up on Ray Kurzweil you're like
and now Alex Friedman special Elon Musk
and he blew me out of the water so I
don't want to be petty about I want to
say that I don't could I am yeah okay
okay the funny part he's not taking
enough risk like he's trying to get us
to Mars imagine that he got us to Mars
the moon and we'll throw in Titan and
know we're good enough the
diversification level is too low now
there's a compatibility first of all I
don't think he Lana's serious is about
Mars
I think Elon is using Mars as a
narrative as a stories and or make them
to make the moon jealous
it makes them I think he's using it as a
story to organize us to reacquaint
ourselves with our need for space our
need to get off this planet it's a
concrete thing he's shown that many
people think that he's shown that he's
the most brilliant and capable person on
the planet I don't think that's what he
showed I think he showed that the rest
of us have forgotten our capabilities so
he's like the only guy who has still
kept the faith and is like what's wrong
with you people
so you think the lesson we should draw
from Elon Musk is there's a is a capable
person within within a lot of us you own
make sense to me in what way
he's doing what any sensible person
should do he's trying incredible things
and he's partially succeeding partially
failing to try to solve the obvious
problems before uh yeah you know but he
comes up with things like you know I got
it we'll come up with a battery company
but batteries aren't sexy so well we'll
make a car around it like great you know
or any one of a number of things
Elon is behaving like a same person and
I view everyone else's insane and my
feeling is is that we really have to get
off this planet we have to get out of
this we have to get out of the
neighborhood don't linger on a little
bit do you think that's a physics
problem or an engineering problem
he's a cowardice problem I think that
we're afraid that we had four hundred
hitters of the mind like Einstein and
Dirac and that that era is done and now
we're just sort of copy editors so it's
some of it money like if we become brave
enough yeah go outside the solar system
can we afford to financially well I
think that's not really the issue the
issue is look what Elon did well he
amassed a lot of money and then he you
know he plowed it back in and he spun it
spun the wheel and he made more money
and now he's got a few money now the
problem is is that a lot of the people
who have a few money are not people
whose middle finger you ever want to see
I want to see II Long's middle finger I
want to see what I mean by that or like
when you say it I'm gonna do the
biggest close do whatever the you
want Yeah right you anything
that gets in his way that he can afford
to push out of his way and you're saying
he's not actually even doing that enough
no I mean he's not going please I'm
gonna go Elon is doing fine with his
money I just want him to enjoy himself
have the most you know Diane Issa you
know but you're saying Mars is playing
it
he doesn't know how to do anything else
he knows rockets yeah and he might know
some physics at a fundamental level yeah
I guess okay just let me just like go
right back to it how much physics do you
really how much brilliant breakthrough
ideas on the physics side do you need to
get off this planet I don't know and I
don't know whether like in my most
optimistic dream I don't know whether my
stuff gets us off the planet but it's
hope it's hope that there's a more
fundamental theory that we can access
that we don't need you know whose
elegance and beauty will suggest that
this is probably the way the universe
goes like you have to say this weird
thing which is this I believe and this I
believe is a very dangerous statement
but this I believe I believe that my
theory points the way now Elon might or
might not be able to access my theory I
don't know I don't know what he knows
but keep in mind why are we all so
focused on you on it's really weird it's
kind of creepy to what he's just a
person who's just asking the the obvious
questions and doing whatever he can but
he makes sense to me you sent craig
venter makes sense to me Jim Watson
makes sense to me but we're focusing on
Elon because he somehow is rare well
that's the weird thing like we've come
up with a system that eliminates all
Elon from our pipeline and Elon somehow
snuck through when they were quality
adjusting everything you know
you